united
and determined to be heard in bangkok
tens of thousands of pro-democracy
protesters rallied
[Applause]
he's shouting for the prime minister to
resign
they want new elections a new
constitution
they're demanding change what do you
want
the government to do get out
that's all get up and
and spend his life in prison so
if the government don't change you'll
keep protesting
yeah i'm not i'm not going to stop i'm
going to break the wall
i
and some here have crossed a traditional
red line
calling for reform of the monarchy an
institution
protected from criticism by strict
defamation laws
we should be able to talk publicly about
the monarchy like they do in other
countries
talking about the monarchy is not
overthrowing it
in the shadow of the grand palace they
made the sign of resistance
but some went further ignoring orders to
leave
and pushing past police
[Applause]
[Music]
the protesters have just broken through
the fence which was the line that the
authorities set
to stop them uh from coming this far
they've just broken through it they're
moving the process which is peaceful
forward but that is
a real taboo moment
these protests have been happening
almost daily since
july the government says it will listen
to their demands
and isn't against the demonstrations as
long as they stay within the law
the government is not trying to
discourage them to do anything
but just asking them to avoid any kind
of
violence
this is the biggest protest since the
2014
coup and support keeps on growing
challenging thailand's most powerful
institutions
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok